[Applause]
some I'm happy to the physician who
study from University and also looking
at al-quran and she'll be talking about
al-quran today
okay hello everybody it's good to be a
speaker in the afternoon because with
the talks in the morning we heard a lot
about the world blogger chase what proof
it is well the better in here Raymond is
what the negative bursary is so nice to
keep all this so I'm gonna tell you
something about our grant it is a
consensus of protocol and based on the
current system protocol as the product
level we have shipped out a public
reflection network that is now running
everybody can go on and test and try it
out today I'm going to most likely focus
only because this is a protocol side but
I'm also going to tell us something
about recent development and the roadmap
and in particular as a theoretician
working as a company I realized that I
have to constantly wear my practical hat
to remember myself to remind myself that
ok your design have to be implementable
by the engineers otherwise doesn't make
sense and so on so forth
so you're just talking about here
missing a lot about jumping jumping in
between is this true like you see a ABC
the XYZ he impractical so you will hear
some of some of those differences
ok so I'll skip you know everybody knows
about work and mining and about the true
stakes we have delegate Bruce takes
where bountiful stakes and the
algorithms proof stake system we
consider it called pure Pro stake I in
the following sense lasers no
punishments needed meaning that
malicious behavior cannot do harm to the
system following but any analysis
somebody may MIDI meter from the
protocol
when we see them even double signing
things would not punish them or take
money from their account because truly
they can't hurt the protocol and we
would you know that that's that's a
protection and another another way
another feature is that we do not ask
the user to lock up tokens interstate in
either account different from like
bonded through fake also money is always
at your fingertips as a key she enjoys
that design choice is that we do not
want to give particular advantages to
big stakeholders because it's like the
more money you have the more you can put
aside without touching and a poor user
who relies on his balances in the bank
account for daily life it is very
unlikely to be able to lock up something
in the system without ever ever ever
touching it for a long time so to us we
always allow you to spend all the
balance that you have in the system and
it is whatever balance you haven't spend
yet will end up being your voting power
in a system the assumption is that the
most of the money isn't on his hands by
most we need more than two-thirds
following the pending agreement and all
the tokens have the same voting powers
you were seeing in our pro snake design
that you know there there are not
different tokens with different
functionalities so that's the zest of
the pure proof stake system and in terms
of the concepts of the protocol it is
permissionless meaning that users can
send up and join the system anytime they
want there's really no nobody knows how
many user who is controlling how many
public keys how many users there are
actually you know what fraction of the
public key is controlled by honest user
or malicious user and etc so system is
really open to everybody and
the adversary which we consider is a
dynamic adversary who can corrupt users
and fully control their behavior but
then it cannot corrupt more than sit to
serve them total stake and at some point
when it no it uncorrupt users you know
recovers to its full state and function
from from there so that's a dynamic
anniversary the protocol the the the
belen agreement itself is pretty simple
it uses ever you know ever-changing
randomly selected the committee to vote
randomly select the leaders proposals
I'm not going to have into details about
the voting and chorim's but those those
are very simple steps and there is no
common clocks users you do not really
need a continuous clock a user need a
timer the timer only needs like count
for certain amount of time and the being
reset and so on so the timer's now what
are the guarantees we guarantee a
synchronous safety meaning that even the
system is totally a synchrony network is
partitioned messages make it a virtual
delays and even in that case the system
still current is that there's no fork
and only web blog is ever certified at a
certain height and so the system is what
we call partition resilient now in terms
of liveness life nice guaranteed when
the messages are propagated in the
network and reaches honest users within
a known time bound of course you know
propagation is a natural natural
replacement of you know theoretical
broadcast models and in applications of
name propagation is Weatherly used I
want to say something about asynchronous
here we all know that
deterministic protocols in a
asynchronous setting you can't hope to
get both safety and the liveness
together they have to go with well done
now for randomized by the agreement
there is a line of literature working on
randomizing protocols
there are randomized protocols that
achieving total asynchrony you know in
like polynomial time and so on but the
parameters there are not really what we
want in a practical system for example a
most very recent work by Valerio King
and students they have randomized by the
name portico in total synchrony it
caused a synchrony communication time is
n cube commutation time is expected
polynomial time I do not really remember
the the formula but the only tolerate in
militias a fraction of an over 10 to the
6
meaning well meaning that if you have a
meaning user in the system and you
tolerate one malicious user that that
was pretty up-to-date today about
randomized agreements so that's not
really what we are looking at in
practice and here we made this trade-off
between a sinfulness safety and
aliveness within if there is a bounded
time for propagation
okay now what is a structure of the Qian
and how are the blocker generated uh
well what I want to emphasize a work
chan because it's really it's really a
chan period there is no soft work the
blocks are generated well after another
following the bedroom here Raymond
versus you know we have been talking
about the proof work and bit corn and we
talk about blockchain but in Bitcoin is
really like a tree as we have seen
earlier talks so there is a mining tree
and there are many branches and you
follow the longest chip and so on now
what's uh what's advantages what's what
a property that gains us from this
having this chain there's no soft fork
because there's no proof work
there's no mining and it gives us two
things
what is immediate transaction finality
you know the moment our transaction
appears on blockchain you can rely on
immediately another is that it's pretty
light with heater for user to
participate in insert a protocol like I
used to run a node on my laptop even
within virtual machine a colleague of my
Porsche to another limit he set up his
node our Raspberry Pi which is like very
low end hardware cost about $100 but any
agreement I feel this is the audience I
really do not need to say again whatever
the agreement is I just want to say
about in a building agreement is a very
important idea in the design but there
are many other pieces in a system that
makes the hosting altri work what are
the challenges we were just looking at a
bit and hear agreement and trying to try
to do it in a permissionless system
first thing is about commutation
communication that we really want to
make it efficient because we are talking
about millions of users and they are in
the whole world
rather than a constraint a very compact
environment but that's not the the
biggest challenge
the biggest challenge is really that in
classical building agreement environment
we typically study a fixed set of users
their end users and F of them are
malicious CF is no more than and n is
more than three F plus one
Emma's II this is n it fixed knowing in
advance but that's definitely not true
on the Internet
and for a permissionless blockchain you
really do not know how many users are
participating and you really do not know
who is having how many public keys so to
conquer those challenges so those are
you know our ins by the arraignment
pretty simple you said web messages per
per step
and this is the the proposer voting
paradigm and if the proposer is honest
you're finishing two steps and if the if
the proposal is malicious then it still
finishes in in constant
expected constant number of steps but
I'm not going to say details about the
building agreement but one is that it's
still not enough to simply run about any
agreement with a billion users if it
finishes in two steps the leader of the
proposal the domain guy is honest and
the protocol actually offers you a new
step further than two steps the new
honest you know that the leader is
malicious
so should you not stop right away no
because you cannot distinguish whether
there is malicious leader or the network
is partitioned if the network is
partition is possible for a malicious
view leader to actually finalize a block
but hide it without telling anybody and
in that case you really do not want the
people to to read to think that oh
there's no block being generated and we
should have a new proposal and propose a
new plug in this round and they will
agree on that the you then the adversary
could release that a block and you have
a
for so we finishes in two steps if the
leader is honest and the network is a
foreign cracked yes we live - is when
the network is not partition yeah okay
yeah ah you know the ideas of dealing
with this probably the very simple all
tomorrow you just publicly select a set
of users and let them being the
committee members that are relevant in
the agreement and this can be easily
done first on will you take the hash you
use a hash and you take the input with
users identifier and the corresponding
wrong number a similar hash to the
random Oracle now you get a random
permutation of the users you by sorting
them according to the hash output now if
you take the first thousand smallish
hash your randomly selecting a thousand
represented a sudden committee members
so what is the problem here the problem
here is that by having a public
selection not only the honest user in a
system knows who is in charge but also
the malicious user the adversary knows
though in advance and they can target
other people and corrupt them therefore
by the time they are supposed to be in
charge all of them have been corrupted
and you do not have a honest majority in
the select the users and therefore if we
see schemes using public selection
typical assumptions are such that it
takes a long time to corrupt a user long
time is much longer than the time a
committee is in charge so by the time
the user is corrupted or the work are
already done and the corruption has no
no influence in you know committees work
we do not really need that assumption
and indeed here is easy adversary' model
it can immediately corrupt any user and
was corrupted the other version can
perfectly control and coordinate all the
users messages including what message to
send when to send and
to whom to sent and the adversary can
attack the protocol like Sonny wrong
messages deviating from the messages and
attacking these the network meaning like
partitioning the network delaying the
messages but the verdict cannot afford
signatures that's that's a basic we need
to rely on that it cannot break more
than cryptography so idea here is well
pretty cute and very simple if you
realize it you realize that it works its
cryptographic self-selection here's a
key keywords in self ah what I mean by
self self means that each user runs its
own individual secret lottery and
selects itself to participate enable any
agreement that's sort of you know sort
of contra intuitive if you think about
the physical lottery ticket system in
the real world like in a physical
lottery system lottery tickets always
printed by a central entity to make sure
that you know there are certain amount
of winning tickets and proportional to
the large amount of ticket to be printed
and then the tickets are distributed and
sold to universe why we can't allow user
to print their own tickets at home
because if they can do that a user may
not print a single ticket but may end up
printing a thousand tickets and only
showed you a winning ticket if it gets
one and the height of the other 999
tickets but with crypto primitives out
of this can can be done digitally which
is very cute so what I'm going to say a
little bit about it but first of all
what is the advantage of this self
selection the advantage here is as there
is no communication needed for the users
to do the self selection but yourself
slaps himself if he's elected he sends
out his baton in voting message together
with his proof that he wins
so what are these biases buys us two
things
what is that the communication cost is
low that it's people - no need to send
extra messages to figure out who is
selected it's just your own parenting
agreement message together with your
signature the second the second
advantage is really about safety that
because there is no communication the
divorce really has no idea about who to
correct before actually seeing their
voting messages and the typical model
about the probation network is a you
know the moment you see his message you
of course knows he's chosen but then is
too late for the diversity to hurry up
this user because they cannot call back
the message being perfectly if the time
is lying not for example but here the
steps are very very fast like even with
seconds well first of all you're
basically talking about the buying vote
in any election system I think that's a
problem in' being will have to stay with
here we're not introducing rationality
we're talking about the honest versus
malicious if a person is honest means
that he stick to whatever the protocol
tells him to to do and if his malicious
he can do whatever he wants yeah we're
not talking about rationality or game
theory analysis about this protocol
we're talking about a user is honest or
malicious I'm just trying to understand
the strength of your statement about
corruption or incorruptibility of your
system if I publish my winning ticket
weeks in advance seconds and iPhones
that believe that I'm ready to be
corrupted and as soon as I had my
winning ticket I'm trying to sell it
yeah very good question that's why in
the system actually a user is able to
figure out that he's in charge of say
the next round two runs are had each run
is about like four point five seconds so
you cannot redo it if you cause damage
to your to the blockchain this is
damaging your own into a blockchain
where you no longer have tokens so there
is an issue here that unlike work when
people can do without being invested in
the blockchain
hiren proof of stage you're risking your
own money so it's a little bit of just
goes to the rationality of things but it
definitely else's familiar with this
line of argument but technically how
long in advance or how long in the
future does my state determine my
lottery ticket there is a difference
between your stake determines your loss
or take his versus at the what time you
will figure out that next round you will
be in charge because you have time to
escape the system and in which case I
can get a lottery ticket which is
winning
nothing at stake as people say you want
to be able to know whether you have a
women takers are losing so the stick is
about something like you computed the
stake using a snapshot of the chain in
weeks before is the time Elaine
which I which which I have between the
time I use my ticket and between the
time I I know that I have one and I'm
asking when do you compute the stake
it's an average really like you say this
thing is a look better parameter I think
it's about eighty or hand your age runs
back so I feel ya a few minutes and then
I will talk about the random selection a
bit more even though you cannot this is
how it is on the system or analyzes
security like a hundred runs a had it's
very hard for you to predict whether the
randomness of seeds will be a hundred on
the from now so that at that point is
very harmful to see you have a winning
yeah this is this is the gadget that
we're using to generate the lottery
well unique signatures and we are
thinking by now the sort of everybody
knows about them unique signature is
different just as its name it's a
signature scheme but if if if the signer
execute the signing procedure with the
same message multiple times he already
previews the unique signature that will
be accepted by the verification
algorithm we cannot just print your
tickets randomly at home and here is the
a little bit of detail so let's say
right now we are trying to generate
block R and Block B 1 PR minus 1 I've
been generated and then the song would
deduce a seed from the first R minus 1
blocks and this is this can be done by
each individual user and each user will
individually site and will hash it and
we'll compare this with a thread hood
property for him to be selected that's
some system parameter question
it depends on several things I think it
depends on the past two blocks no no it
doesn't depends on the content of the
block that's crucial
yeah otherwise you know proof of work
like honest user do not need to do
prover by the militia user could
manipulate the content and many
production yeah so if if he passes us
right who didn't send a message and send
a signature as his certificate as his
credential now that is you know that
prevents a committee member being
figured out by the adversary' in advance
but that I would say I wanna solve the
problem for the first step of the
program because if this user is in
charter for the whole consists of the
protocol the protocol has magical steps
then after the first step
well I started okay he says that fast
okay all right I'll speed up I think
we're we're probably done with tech news
part so what am i saying is that this
this if you think about is some of the
first step problem after the first step
everybody sees a credential already and
can terribly corrupt them in a second
step and the third step and so on the
problem is still existing so what's a
what's the idea here is as abandoning
agreement has another nice property we
could use a replace parity meaning that
when there are multiple steps we can do
a random selection each single step
independently from each other and each
step and never with a random committee
member they may not have the same number
of users it they may not have the same
set of users and the product is that it
works because the building equipment
does not have internal variables the
user has to keep in order to make it
work you can't reduce the next message
by observing the political propagating
messages and then we can allow each step
has a separate selection and you know
corrupting step when method users will
not help with improving the probability
of corrupting step to users and so
that's a very cute property okay I think
this part is just about the token so far
I have been not been talking about token
don't talk about users and here in the
two phases of proposing and voting
really where we're not really selecting
users were selecting tokens imagine that
each token has its only RF and a token
get selected means that its owner does
the carries out the duty so the
selection property in a first step a
directly proportional to the tokens and
in a second step about you know a
thousand tokens are random
selected and their owners to the job a
little bit of optimization trick it's
here that you if a user had 10,000 token
you really do not want him to compute
and thousand VRS so the optimization
trick is you can you can for a user he
can decide how many tokens of his it
cost selected by in value it's a simple
single vrf if you think about it for a
longer time I think you can figure out
how to do that okay a little bit about
the committee size and the quorum you
know sir IRA hood sorry differ enough
ramming a classic about environment here
we have two parameters we can control
well is the expected committee size
which will dictate the selection
probabilities and one is a quorum surah
hood that among these committee members
how many signatures I need to see to
make my next move
the conditions are said so that you know
with a given on this ratio you choose
this two parameters so that with high
probability the first condition is a
safety condition that you can't generate
two conflicting certificates and the
second condition is a liveness condition
that even if the militia you do nothing
and there's if the network is no
partitioned honest users in stem cells
can generate agreement so little bit of
probabilistic analysis oh well still
there are many other ideas for the
utimately protocol you know infirmary
keys separately spending keys and the
voting keys and you know is raising the
keys and acceptor is really feel like
there are many many gadgets in the
system when the agreement is very
important piece and there many pieces
and really you figure out one piece
there's another piece and and you
finally you figure out the whole piece
and suddenly it becomes stabilized and
the whole thing works
that's that's really how the
architecture fits together so a little
bit of summary you know on its majority
of money and there's no mining so
competition in
simple there's no mining pools and all
the users can participated with our
tokens for keen probability this is how
we chose the parameter in the system we
were fixed what is the error property we
want to tolerate a little reason
backward to set the parameters and the
parameter is pretty low the property is
pretty low that 10 to the minus 18 is
sort of like the age of the universe and
you can you can basically you can
basically reach consensus about the
blocks
well the block is being propagated so
it's pretty fast and the we tolerate a
dynamic anniversary okay I think I'm
that's a good question
right a little bit of recent development
well I see where our other time okay
yeah okay I think I already communicated
the most of the key ideas in a system so
I will just stop here and welcome
everybody to check out them and that
which is already running
[Applause]